what's going on man how are you bill
hader we're glad you could come in
earlier the time we're happy to see you
yeah
congratulations by the way seventeen
Emmy nominations four for Barry does it
did it really like you I'm obviously you
want to win with you obsess over that no
I would you would yeah of course I'm no
I don't really I mean it's out of your
control and it's just like a nice like a
nice thing they give you and you're like
oh my gosh and I and it sounds like you
know you know whatever no one believes
this stuff but it really is like with so
many TV shows just to be like in the mix
on that you're like are you kidding well
you're happy yeah because all those
shows on there I mean fleabag I thinks
like genius I love that show I've
actually watched it twice and I'm in
last year the same thing that Atlanta I
just watched it more than once full
seasons oh these things are great so you
watch everything I don't watch that
stuff you watch all them I don't watch
all of it i watch stuff i am i kind of
interested or anything that's kind of in
that yeah everything yeah usually
interested in I try to catch it in catch
so since you create tell a television
show though when you see something that
you're like that's genius is there any
part of you that goes like [ __ ] why
can't I be that genius no well no it's
just two separate things you know I mean
the biggest thing I might come out of it
is you know you watch something and go I
mean we could probably um you know it's
a good thing to you know maybe pay more
attention to our dialogue you know
fleabag the dialogue in that is so good
you know might be something like that or
you know watching Atlanta and say oh we
we could probably be more cinematic or
something but it's very small you know
if you that healthy Jim no what would
you be sitting there going like I'm
watching I say you know why you know the
or probably came from was being on
Saturday alive and just you know when
you start there it's so competitive for
so long but you you know you you just
have to in order to like survive just to
kind of like let go of things and go oh
man that was so good you know I'm right
over my first season you're trying to
stay on anything and get fired and then
those guys did lazy Sunday and I was
just like
not mad but just like why didn't I think
of something like what am i doing but
then you just realize it's all kind of
waves and it's like I wrote a rap song
about Star Wars guys think about this
now yeah you just say as long as you're
just you realize yeah I realized that
SNL the only thing I can control is the
output you know what I was writing and
you know that was it we should think
when you have that I was gonna say when
you have that SNL pressure does it make
other pressures go like this is this is
way easier like when you're in a really
bad relationship mm-hmm
it makes it really easy to deal with the
little problems of yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh this is nothing
right yeah this is nothing right Eddie
is gonna guest host this year and I said
everyone's talking about it is there it
was when you were there I was there
people who would guest host where
there'd be like that is there a
different energy in the league in the
building when a guy like that is going
to guest host or two people they just
don't give a [ __ ] after at this point I
mean it's you know it is a different
energy maybe it's in my experience is
like the top of the week and then by
Friday you're just like everybody else
everyone's tired and you're like oh hey
what's going on you know Mick Jagger
came in oh my god make Jagger and then
by the end of the Friday relay hey dude
you're not on your mark used to it fast
yeah yeah yeah and also you're just
tired so your defense that entered that
nervousness kind of like can go away and
you know you have to perform in front of
people live on television pressure that
is a lot more bigger than yeah it's
usually weirdly in retrospect like I
remember I did Robert DeNiro hosted and
I mean you know he's one of my heroes as
far as an actor I mean growing up
watching him and everything and it
didn't hit me and tell I was walking in
the hall like two years later and saw a
picture that they had framed of us that
I was like God I performed with the near
home yeah oh that's so wild right you
know what I mean but in the moment
you're so like worried about the sketch
and yeah about the performing live
television and all this stuff and by the
way we're doing another show next week
yeah next week
by the way we got someone else next
weekend do you have any ideas and you
know you just your minds so preoccupied
with so much bangs when you got like
that pitch is a sketch does everybody do
like the guest host pitch sketches as
well yeah yeah what do you do if I get
to narrow pitches a sketch instinct or
Jagger or somebody you try it
mmm you know you try it and you try to
dress and hopefully they'll see like oh
that doesn't work and or they don't then
it goes great you know it goes great at
dress and I've had that happen before
we're all like what is this thing we're
doing and then you do it a dress and it
kills and you know I know something we
don't I guess you know do you develop a
confidence when when you get to the
point that you got to where you're in
more sketches than you're not in and
you'd be kind of you kind of become one
of the go-to guys that everybody uses
does that sort of early like oh I don't
wanna get fired thing go away because
you realize the I don't wanna get fired
thing goes away but for me the being on
live television anxiety never went away
I was always like well god this is
terrible just the lead up to it is awful
do you enjoy being on movie sets yeah
you get a second take it's not live and
right around and you can kind of mess up
and that no one cares and it's so funny
because it's almost like you I feel like
on some level you it's I mean I guess
it's because I'm not on very many movie
sets but I'd be like worried about oh I
don't want to disrupt like there's so
many people here they're counting on
this they're Beauvoir oh yeah but
they're all it's all like because now
I've been on every side of it they want
you to do well so as long as you know I
mean if they're cool they just want you
to do well and yeah make you comfortable
and you have just it me really is just
having a second take all my anxiety was
down to like I have one chance to land
this on national television and if I
don't it's gonna stink and you know if
it's bombing comedy you know if it's
like working or not immediately the
worst feeling on earth where I can hear
my footsteps
during this
and I'm like going oh my god you know
there's a spot on the Comedy Cellar
stage where I step and I can hear like
hear the creaky and when you're
performing and I hear that I'm like they
have to hear that you're back and they
know that it's not getting what you get
that's the worst
thudding across the stage oh my god yeah
I did a sketch I've done so many
sketches we okay we did this one sketch
with Josh Brolin we didn't one called
fart face with Josh Brolin that bomb
terribly which was a shocker right but
it was it was me in a Will Forte and we
were businessman and that bomb and then
Josh Brolin did another one where he's
talking about the fall foilage my saying
that word right footage foliage and and
it's him just going anybody gone up to
see the fall foilage huh no it's a big
business thing he's like the buttery
Browns the beautiful yellows but and
we're all and the whole thing is that we
just don't say anything and and it
bombed so bad
live television just silence and then he
leaves and then I started laughing
because Kenan Thompson had to say this
line that is so offensive and terrible
which he goes I went and saw him this is
awful I'm not is not funny he said I
went and saw him to go to foliage and
they go yeah and I was and he goes he
allowed me to be raped
[Laughter]
he's we're waiting I start laughing cuz
Kenan the look on his face was like I
gotta say this [ __ ] line after the
thing just H knowing that you're not
punctual now it's like and this thing is
gonna just make it worse how did that
line work oh I think you actually could
hear people going no just chilled the
room completely derailed the whole I
feel like it derailed the rest of the
like no nothing worked after that what
are you doing you walk off after such a
bomb and it's a team effort you know you
know
wrote none of us wrote lukina didn't
write this getcha no one wrote it I felt
bad for him and you but that would
happen all the time or you would just
get a limelight better you have to play
a character and you're like I just feel
really weird about those guys and and
then you just in your head you're like I
hope you'll know I didn't write this and
you know it's bombing immediately Oh
immediately the minute goes out just the
audience to look on their faces just
know is there is there much less
pressure to do something like you did
for it like when it's a dramatic role
like I'm sure that you know I mean when
you're not there to necessarily make
people laugh every 25 seconds yeah I
mean yeah I mean nothing's like Saturday
Night Live because I mean even doing it
you know or barrier or any I mean even
doing super bad you know there's no like
real pressure you know like that you
know as far as having to be funny you
know cuz you could try certain things
and it doesn't feel funny on the on the
set but then they cut it in a way where
it's hysterical
you know what I mean I mean you get a
different way of doing it but on SNL or
like you're saying stand-up I mean
that's the worst we're just immediately
and you're in the room performing it and
there's no way you can't consciously go
this isn't working
so they always know it like when you're
watching and like they're doing it like
you know that they know they're bombing
right right they don't it's not like
they don't know and then sometimes you
just towards the end of the season kind
of go back to earlier question I did a
sketch with Justin Bieber where I was
like this old country music star and he
was my son and we were singing a song
and it just it bombed so bad and the
wall almost fell on Justin Bieber like
the set started falling apart on the
sketch they didn't bring me any of the
right props oh man it was just one of
those things where I just kind of you
just kind of like you just slowed down
and just like almost bask and how
terrible it's going right and then that
becomes really fun did he know was going
bad no yes a lot of times people who are
not in comedy they don't think that was
pretty fun and you like that
I'm terrible but both so you're like no
one is laughing what do you mean that
went great that's when I would go nuts
like a thing with BOM and then you would
walk off and someone go that was great
don't lie to me
would you tell us something so if a
celebrity guest host were to think it
was like that's pretty good right would
you be like no depends on who it was
yeah you know if it was like Paul Rudd
or someone like that you'd be like oh
god no me and I went bad you know or
whatever but it was someone like yeah
Justin Bieber you're not gonna go what
was that you know a comedian right
because there are people who tell them
was great too as soon as he walks off
his people oh my god that was amazing
that was so funny you're so funny the
indicator is so funny didn't happen
which is this no one no one was laughing
but it does it does give you a peek into
like what mentality goes into the
decision-making on that level of
celebrity because you have people around
you that would just be sitting there
trying to convince you that things are
as they aren't like things are good even
if they're not good and maybe you want
to be convinced of that no I like it
when people are like that was terrible
right that didn't work out let me or or
just let me figure it out on my own
because sometimes people go it was
terrible and you want is that reverse
happens and you watch by you know this
bet played what are you talking about
that was okay it wasn't like gangbusters
but look back I don't laugh that gotta
laugh you know you know how did you know
how to judge it honestly without like
hearing it some people hear everything
in the hero laugh with everything and
it's just yeah and I also when I was
there is probably so kind of like overly
sensitive and you know exaggerated in my
mind you know what I mean I'll go well
that was awful that was terrible you
know and it's like you can't convince me
otherwise and then yeah you you know you
see it back or somethingö actually the
best is when you go when you know you're
too sensitive about your own stuff and
you go that felt like it was horrible
but I'm probably being too sensitive and
then you go back and watch it and you go
off I was a pretty good judge of it
usually usually of it just and and and
kind of again your point like the longer
I was there yeah it wasn't so much
confidence it was more of like a coping
or managing it where you just go oh I
could just turn in my stuff and that's
it and I think a thing that Seth Meyers
kind of taught me when I was there and
any any Poehler as well as like this
place is competitive it's like the DNA
or the place but we don't have to be
competitive with each other which is
like nice right like you'd like the
performers can cooperate you can like be
excited for people like yeah I'm not
watching Keenan doing what up with that
and I played Lindsay bucking and I don't
say anything that sketch and it was I
was just watching him perform and it's
like just oh every time we do it like
making so good yeah he was just like
dancing and like and it's all new stuff
a lot of the time where I'm like oh wait
when they add that they must have just
ahead of that like that wasn't a dress
wow this is great
you get jealous no I'm never like a real
jealous person I it's more like you know
it's like yeah it's like you watch those
TV shows you oh man that's good we
should remember to kind of do this yeah
but it's like separate stuff like not
meaning the live performers when you
watch it a guy kill a now no I don't
know I don't know I'm like either yeah
either it's like I'm I'm in a good place
or I'm like a manic depressed like just
giving up on some level no I think it's
not a diet it's not a job that's it no I
was always anytime Will Forte would do
is sketch late I always want to go on
the floor and watch it because there was
a chance it would kind of like just
shake the audience because it was so
strange or something and I just loved it
yeah when you're depressed is it because
it works stuff or do you just get it for
no rational reason at all I know I say
that I was kind of a joke I my problems
more anxiety it's less like depression
more like I get really anxious about
it's more like and yeah it's like wait
call it anticipatory anxiety it's okay
we're about to go on you know do I have
my you know do I know what I'm gonna say
do I know what I'm gonna do is this
gonna go well is that well this could
happen this could happen this can happen
but I after it's done I don't really
look back what was the schedule like on
that I'm the anxiety was the
wouldn't the anxiety just kick in like
right before you're going onstage or
like right around Thursday Friday to you
oh okay we already show on Saturday it
changed as I was on the show when I
first started it was like Monday pitch
meeting I was like I can't breathe and
then by the time I was you know like you
know last couple of years of right
before the show had started it would
just write hit and in what you would do
is you're just kind of oh all right here
we go
here it is instead of fighting it it's
just like all right let's just there
this happened there are people that say
like they like the anxiety because it
means that they're still passionate
they're still interested do you think
that that's true or would you have nah -
mine was like I had the flu it was it
really was like Marlon would start
spinning and I would be like I might
pass out and I mean it was really and
then I just felt like everybody was like
god you're so dramatic
I'm not being dramatic I'm like serious
guys it can you feel like you're in a
room full of professionals and you're an
amateur yeah exactly they know what
you're doing this feeling how it exactly
that's exactly what it is I would be
sitting there in the meeting before air
and I'm like how is everybody so calm
right now like I'm about to pull my skin
off I'm just so terrifying it's such a
weird thing because going into it you're
like this is my dream job when it's
happening you're like just let this be
over yeah just let it be over and then
once it's over you're like [ __ ] yeah
awesome yet it's just like let's just
get through this and calm and then
there's a nice thing that will happen at
times were in the middle of something
when it's working or you're happy with
what you're doing where you can let go
that stuff and you're just having fun
and right that was that's the best where
you're just you're not in your head and
you're going oh this is this is going
great then you're taking your time and
not rushing and is there any difference
when you started doing stuff after SNL
or a little bit during SNL - when you
were on movie sets and TV sets that were
not Saturday Night Live so it's like you
didn't have this camaraderie of people
that you work with day in day out over
the course of years it's more of a
traditional movie set yeah was it a
weird adjustment at all no I mean I I
tend to like when I show up I try to
you know I tend to make a lot of jokes
and try to like get very comfortable I
hope you do this doer I just said like
when I'm around like that group people
like on a film set and I gotta like
perform in front of them and I might
fail I want to be comfortable failing so
I just start doing bits constantly
probably too much cuz I kind of almost
want a bomb in front of them so I can
relax whereas like I'm just making joke
like on it too we had this big scene in
a Chinese restaurant was our first day
of shooting we shot that way week and I
was like freaking bit City about
everything and then you know like most
of them don't work alright that's good
so then when I'm in the scene and I'm
doing it and it's like not working I'm
kind of you used to be unconscious to
being uncomfortable yeah and this isn't
like a thing I consciously did it was
pointed out to me by someone else and I
because who worked with me on other
movies and they're like you know you did
this on the other movie too or it's like
the first week or so you're heavy bit
city because you're kind of nervous
that's I'm the complete opposite I mean
I'm terribly ashamed and I feel like I'm
an absolute fraud and as soon as I open
my mouth they're all gonna see I admire
what you can do much more because it's
such a way NICTA Paulo is great at that
too where when there's a situation Nick
will just fire out jokes but he doesn't
care whose it to read whatever it is
bump bump bump some work some don't but
he's you could see how [ __ ] funny he
is by the way he's firing stuff and
that's even when a joke doesn't work you
still admire the confidence of somebody
who's in that situation comfortable so I
admire guys who can do that yeah Marty
shorts that way just and social settings
are Martin Short will just like just
make jokes jokes jokes and summer funny
summer don't but then you just they're
like wow okay you're just totally it
relaxes him yeah and he's and he's but
he's good at doing Bob Kelly did that we
were at a Thanksgiving dinner and Philip
Seymour Hoffman was there and neither of
us knew him he just happened to be and
Bob Kelly was so [ __ ] funny Bob
bumble and I just sat there Oh like I
couldn't function in a situation the
fact that he could yeah it's amazing I
feel like I stay
anxious and quiet until people just take
for granted that I'm there yeah
and then once that that taking for
granted thing is done then I'm more
comfortable because I'm just there now
yeah I just never want to be in a
position where I'm like overthinking
what I'm about to say so I just kind of
go all right you know you don't want to
be obnoxious but you know you just being
like hey we're having fun and then and
then you know and then people then I go
oh well half of those like most of that
didn't work I'm afraid it would backfire
though and I was just not to like you
see this video of DeNiro and Don Rickles
on the set of casino where Rickles is
scolding and for not knowing his lines
but he's laughing cause it's funny oh my
god it's so funny but my fear would be
to do that and have somebody go oh oh oh
he can't yes you are I don't read it to
Larry David ones shooting something I
was like what are you talking about and
I just said that in my whole stomach
just like you know like with one of your
friends yeah what are you talking about
and I my stomach you know he was fine
you know and I mean he was super nice
and it's probably and but it was that
experience it could have totally
backfire
it's terrible man you realize I go oh my
god did I just step out of line with mr.
David yeah I mean what comedians I
shouldn't let me have a comedian get
like that I'd be like what yeah like
what are you talking
comedians are probably okay with yeah
teasing them yeah it would just be my
fear I admire the ability to do that
it's amazing was there anybody
specifically in the it to cast that you
were like nervous about or anything or
was it just a new set just a new setting
and hoping that you know you're gonna do
well and you know it's like is sequel to
a big movie and so you're like oh gosh I
hope this goes alright but if you're
thinking about that stuff you'll go
crazy so I think SNL totally helped me
with all that we just have to throw it
all out and go you know what none of
those you know none of this matters just
have just do good work right do work
that you're happy with that's all you
can do that's the only thing you can
control because what we're talking about
really is like trying to control a thing
and it's like you can't so you just have
to just let go when you're doing a
when you do a horror film like that and
the clown is such an evil shitty being
like when this you're in between takes
are you actually just having a regular
conversation or is he the type of guy
that just wants to walk off no no no
bill Sarsgaard is one of the nicest guys
in the world no we're just bullshitting
and I'm like how are you doing man are
you do you want like see these contacts
in fake teeth in he's like I mean he's
just they were pouring ice down his back
because it would get hot in that bang
and it was super hot out and Toronto
last summer and I was just like
but you David how are you doing he's
like I'm fine I'm fine like you never
complained and we just [ __ ] about
you know movies and remember he got me a
drink at this place it was so weird he
was like I might you gotta get this this
whiskey at this plane sometimes I
remember turns like what was it thing I
drink last night he's like oh no no it's
here let me get him my phone he's
dressed as the clown like drink anything
weird no no it's just really cool like
whiskey thing all right because I don't
drink a lot and it really kind of laid
me out man and what was that but he's
got the big forehead he's got the big
forehead give me my phone cuz you can't
keep the phone anywhere the facial
recognition is like you know reckons
like who the [ __ ] are you so you're
happy with how it came out yeah I just
saw it last week at the premiere and I
was like Jesus big movie like well you
know the other people in the movie light
is a Mustapha PJ ransom Jay Ryan and
Andy bean you know the other some of the
other guys afterwards we were all just
going like might think another every J
right how old is Jaron Jay Ryan is he's
a New Zealand actor different guy I'm
thinking of we saw a trailer for a show
that never got picked up called where's
Rodney
Oh Jay Thomas is the guy who I said okay
Jay Tom okay he's passed away yeah JJ
Thomas on in living color I don't know
I'm like Murphy Brown is on a whole
bunch of second show
I mind I'm thinking only thing at J
Leggett yeah there was a pilot for show
called where's Rodney where Rodney would
show up and it was not a particularly
good this kid was a fan of Rodney and he
could summon Rodney give him a life
advice and they did a sea of a doll I
would love to ask her about it it was in
the pilot and it was a pilot where uh
it's abroad he just shows up and does
his bits and it was really Thea Vidale
Breckin Meyer was in it the girl played
Punky Brewster was in oh there was other
people yeah just play this song four
times you never seen the theme song
probably not the best so this is the
pilot it wasn't a particularly good part
for a pilot that would have starred
Rodney Dangerfield the pilot did yeah
called where's Rodney is he in this yeah
isn't it is what it would have started
okay right
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no wait is that thinking from big his
friend and big might that might have
been had the same haircut saucy teacher
that's Punky Brewster Wow Leon fry yeah
I only recognize you Meyer yeah okay
Gandhi has an easy money poster did you
see that easy easy money poster remember
that time very funny highly Negron in
that movie goes gonna gonna call you
that yeah that made me laugh so hard
Pesci was so fast yeah directed by the
guy Jim Signorelli who did all the the
Paradiso doesn't know oh really oh
really yeah that's a very funny man I
met him I was like easy money I love the
end of that theme song because the
righty Dangerfield a joke joke he's like
my wife is so dumb yeah just
breastfeeding through a straw they had
the pepper in his axe yeah and she I
think the joke was like my wife is so
dumb it takes her 90 minutes to watch 60
minutes makes for an hour and a half so
are 16 oh I saw something with Rodney on
home improvement recently or he did this
guest thing on home improvement and it's
where they're just trying to get the
jokes and he's doing the jokes but the
cast is laughing because he's supposed
to be rod and it was so he ever got
tired of doing his bits on shows like
well can I just act I think is he was
much older he probably couldn't remember
all this my like someone Caddyshack
wasn't it the thing where he first
started doing his bit and he freaked out
during the first take he started
sweating because no one was laughing oh
yeah Harold Ramis I worked on year one
and that was Harold rain was his last
movie I think he told me that I was like
we was asking about Caddyshack and he
said oh yeah Ronnie danger if it just
started sweating after the first take
and he freaked out he's like no one's
laughing and you guys Ronnie they can't
laugh because of the sound
[Laughter]
supposed to laugh oh wow do you
got surreal life yeah yeah we're done
what did you do it sounds like a post PA
I was like the guy in charge of you know
like taping you know like doing copies
and delivering the dailies to people
that's awesome that was my favorite like
reality show that was when they would
just take like washed up celebrities and
just put him in a house together that's
right just got a guy the guy who is this
guy named Matt bored offski was really
funny and remember he just he treated he
was like one of the producers or he had
a line producer on the show or whatever
and I'm her one time MC Hammer called
him like super mad because a PA and an
accurate came and picked him up from the
airport and he he had him on the
speakerphone and he said this is he goes
he goes what's the problem and he goes
and he was talking about himself in the
third person he said you do not send a
PA in an acura to pick up hammer from
the airport hammer drives in a limousine
to the hotel this is not the way you
treat a celebrity and matt said what
celebrity referring to ID you guys are
friends like that like this guy matt
Rudovsky
he is the quickest funniest guy and I
was like man you gotta do stand-up for
so I honestly I'm telling you I'm doing
this stuff and I still tell him what do
we do he like producers like shows like
that but he's like insanely quick and
funny like that that's amazing
yeah and I get MC Hammer he's sitting
there trying to grasp onto whatever
dignity Kenny knows that the show is
like no not the greatest showcase for
celebrities yeah
but he's like at least if you don't cuz
you not pick me up in an acura yeah
no we're paying you because you are
stuff
what celebrity referring to it I think
so calm and so fast I just was like whoa
hahaha so mean
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]